bonsoir à tous voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce samedi
un samedi et deux finales en rugby tout
d'abord le stade toulousain vient de
s'incliner face aux irlandais de munster
en finale de la coupe d'europe et ce
soir c'est au tour de la coupe de france
de football avec à la fiche lyon et
paris qui rêvent d'un doublé au stade de
france
nous retrouverons denis balbir pour
l'ambiance d'avant-match dans ce journal
un homme tué par un gendarme alors qu'il
tentait de s'évader de la compagnie de
gendarmerie de draguignan dans le var
l'auteur des coups de feu était suspendu
de ses fonctions et placé en garde à vue
une enquête a été ouverte faut-il
craindre une pénurie d'essence à la
pompe la réponse est non pour le moment
la colère du marin pêcheur relative aux
prix des carburants s'est étendue à
plusieurs professions touchés
directement par cette inflation nous
font le point sur la mobilisation
le grand format de ce samedi nous
emmènera en chine où des milliers de
parents pleurent là-bas la disparition
de leur enfant unique
le jour du séisme des milliers d'écoles
se sont effondrés sur les élèves leur
fort sage dans la province du sichuan à
suivre la politique et bertrand delanoë
qui se dit prêt à prendre sa part de
responsabilité dans le parti socialiste
quant à son rôle exact ce seront je cite
les militants qui décideront le maire de
paris a réuni ses partisans aujourd'hui
pour commenter l'actualité politique
iq la première année de mandat du
président sarkozy qu'il avait soutenu et
ses ambitions personnelles avec nous
bernard tapie qui est l'invité ce soir
du samedi 20 heures
un homme de 27 ans donc été tuées la
nuit dernière par un gendarme alors
qu'il tentait de s'évader menotté de la
gendarmerie de draguignan dans le var
l'auteur des coups de feu a été suspendu
de ses fonctions et placé en garde à vue
une enquête interne est ouverte ce soir
sur place la situation est tendue les
faits avec nathalie jourdan et virgile
ados sont venus de brignoles dès qu'ils
ont appris la nouvelle
une quarantaine de gens du voyage des
amis des proches et la veuve ampleur de
joseph garner
se marier c'est en garde à vue à la
gendarmerie de draguignan
il est mort la nuit dernière à l'étoile
anodine à brignoles qui s'est suicidé un
conte à vie s'ils disent qu'ils savent
des poignets qui s'est enlevé les
menottes à prendre l'arrivée veulent pas
nous dire qu'il est le corps mais c'est
quoi ça c'est des meurtriers 22h hier
joseph guerdner est interrogé par les
gendarmes dans le cadre d'une affaire
d'agression et de séquestration d'un
chauffeur routier
sa garde à vue vient d'être prolongée
menotté accompagné d'un gendarme
il est autorisé à fumer une cigarette à
cette fenêtre profitant de l'extinction
de la minuterie dans le couloir il saute
par la fenêtre retombe quatre mètres
plus bas se relève et s'enfuit le
gendarme le somment de s'arrêter avant
de tirer à sept reprises trois balles
vont toucher joseph gerner il parvient
quand même à escalader ce grillage et se
retrouve dans le parc d'un établissement
scolaire religieux il est arrivé
jusqu'ici il est monté en haut de
l'arbre et à un moment il a il sentait
qu'il avait de moins en moins de force
il est tombé sur le bus on est tombé par
terre les gendarmes sont arrivés il
emplit mais nettement les pompiers les
secours ne parviendront pas à le
réanimer
le gendarme lui a immédiatement été
placé en garde à vue
j'ai retenu dans ce qui me concerne la
qualification d'homicide volontaire
j'ai voulu signifier par c'est par cette
qualification que rien n'était laissé de
côté et que la discussion portait sur
l'ensemble des agissements de ceux de ce
militaire l'inspection technique de la
gendarmerie a été saisie elle devra
déterminer s'il usage de larmes s'est
effectué dans le respect de la
réglementation spécifique aux gendarmes
contrairement un policier qui ne peut
tirer qu'en état de légitime défense
un gendarme peut faire flou en cas
d'évasion à condition que ce soit le
seul moyen d'arrêter le fugitif
l'actualité de ce samedi c'est toujours
le bras de fer engagé par lés un marin
pêcheur après les négociations d'hier
avec michel barnier on avait cru un vrai
signe d'apaisement ce matin aux sables
d'olonne les pêcheurs avaient décidé de
suspendre le mouvement affirmant qu'ils
aient souhaité repartir en mer situation
identique à la cotinière en charente
maritime
mais ce soir de nombreux ports restent
toujours bloqués notamment sur la façade
atlantique le conflit qui s'étend même
vous allez le voir à d'autres
professions touchés par la hausse des
prix du carburant
on fait le point sur cette journée de
mobilisation avec caroline thébaux et
nos équipes en région opération péage
gratuit à la gravelle sur l'autoroute
paris rennes
les pêcheurs veulent rallier la
population à leur cause pas toujours
facile sur vous n'êtes vous les autres
pays et groupements les aider aux
cellules temps c'est pas possible
toute aide financière est bonne à
prendre et vous
d'autant que les marins du guilvinec ne
sont pas seuls des agriculteurs
manifestent à leur côté on s'aperçoit
que les pêcheurs sont ces rares qui se
mobilisent mais quand ils se mobilisent
on s'aperçoit que ça paye
s'il faut en arriver là pour qu'on
arrive à obtenir quelque chose eh ben on
a on connaît la recette au frac au mot
dans le sud de la france à port la
nouvelle ce sont des chauffeurs routiers
qui se sont jointes au mouvement des
pêcheurs dur enfin alors que le dépôt de
carburant est bloqué depuis une semaine
je voyais ce que ça devrait suivre parce
que tous les transporteurs même au
niveau européen sont concernés enfin
poisson gratuit à saint gilles croix de
vie en vendée des marins ont pris la mer
pour offrir des sardines aux habitants
symbole d'une grève qui persistent comme
à la rochelle saint malo et arcachon
alors il ne faut pas pour le moment
craindre une pénurie de carburant à la
pompe même si certains comme c'est
souvent le cas se précipitent dans les
stations a la rochelle les dépôts sont
toujours bloqués par les pêcheurs et le
préfet a donc décidé d'organiser le
ravitaillement pour ce week-end
reportage à n'diaye épais et bernard
connor plus une goutte de carburant
depuis hier cette station service à
temps le ravitaillement
on attendait un camion qui devait venir
nous livrer en fait il n'est pas venu
donc c'est à dire on n'a plus de moyens
de livrer les clients et malheureusement
on va fermer bientôt puisque nous
n'avons plus de sens disponibles dans
les ici on a eu plus de chance
exceptionnellement la préfecture a
autorisé la circulation des camions
citernes week-end ce qui permet aux
rochelais de se fournir en essence ou en
gasoil selon les stations rappelé
l'autre une station promet de l'effort
savage la chance la troisième mais un
peu prévoyants simplement
on sait jamais moi j'utilise pas ma
voiture tous les jours mais bon je fais
sûr d'en avoir quand même avec les
enfants c'est plus rationnel prendre
cette précaution mais interdiction
formelle de faire des réserves
je décourage sur tout tout tout réaction
complètement irrationnel de soi disant
précaution ou de constitution de stocks
ça ne se justifie en rien les dépôts de
carburant de la rochelle sont eux
toujours inaccessible bloqué par les
pêcheurs en colère pour nous
personnellement on attend jusqu'à lundi
matin
voilà une réponse contre un vote pour
savoir si on repart au parcours enfin
pour nous pour l'instant on reste sur
nos pauses et si les pêcheurs demandent
toujours un casual moins cher de leur
côté les automobilistes ne regarde plus
à la dépense
il assure la quantité à l'étranger aux
états unis c'est la polémique du jour
hillary clinton a semble-t-il parlé un
peu trop vite la candidate démocrate a
dû finalement s'excuser pour des propos
troublants
elle a ainsi justifié son maintien dans
la course à la maison blanche en faisant
une allusion historique à l'assassinât
de bobby kennedy
en résumé et si barack obama
disparaissez on appelle cela une gaffe à
washington anne valleron la scène se
passe au dakota du sud là où sont
sculptés pour l'éternité les principes
pour président de l'histoire américaine
un état où il ya plus de bison que
d'habitants un des deux derniers a voté
le 3 juin alors que les jeux sont
quasiment faits barack obama est
virtuellement nominés hillary clinton il
fait campagne
dieu sait pourquoi et c'est justement la
question qu'on lui pose mais qu'est ce
qui vous fait donc encore courir alors
qu'on est presque en juin
souvenez-vous bobby kennedy était encore
en campagne en juin quand il a été
assassiné
lagaf est énorme c'est la référence
historique qu'il ne fallait pas évoqué
hillary clinton dit ainsi tout haut ce
que chacun craint tout bas que
l'ascension de barack obama soit arrêtée
en plein vol par la balle d'un tueur
raciste
une fois une seule fois la question est
évoquée sur six minutes
cela ne m'empêche pas de dormir ce que
la vérité c'est que barack en tant que
noir peut se faire tuer dans n'importe
quelle station service on ne peut pas
prendre de décision fondée sur la peur
hillary clinton auraient-elles donc
exprimé inconsciemment l'idée qu'elle
continuer sa campagne parce qu'elle
s'attendait à une tentative de meurtre
au baba plates excuses
je regrette que cette référence
historique traumatisant pour tout le
pays en particulier pour la famille
kennedy
et puis au fond c'est de quelques
manières dans le camp obama on n'a réagi
que par un simple communiqué le candidat
lui même a poursuivi sa campagne bien
encadrés par ses gardes du corps comme
si de rien n'était il sait trop bien
qu'il lui faudra un jour se réconcilier
avec sa rivale
et puis cette information à prendre avec
prudence selon les autorités
colombiennes le numéro 1 des farc manuel
marulanda serait décédé il est l'un des
fondateurs dans les années 60 de la
guérilla qui retient toujours
ingrid betancourt après la birmanie le
secrétaire général des nations unies ban
ki moon était en chine les autorités du
pays avancent désormais le chiffre de 80
mille victimes
et parmi elles des milliers d'enfants à
14h le lundi 12 mai jour du séisme
ils étaient tous à l'école des écoles
qui se sont parfois vous allez le voir
effondrés comme des châteaux de cartes
et la polémique hanche au pays de
l'enfant unique
des milliers de parents ont perdu leurs
trésors ce le grand format de samedi les
signer pascal golomer et et sylvain
guillaume
tous les jours ils sont assis là
silencieux dans la cour de ce qu'ils
étaient l'école de leurs enfants
aujourd'hui l'école primaire de voo foot
est un amas de ruines
127 élèves et y ont péri le jour du
séisme mais c'est le seul bâtiment s'est
effondré dans le village
mes parents accusent le constructeur de
malfaçons et les dirigeants locaux de
corruption ne croyais que vous pouvez
regarder la mauvaise qualité des
matériaux problème pour semer fang comme
pour la plupart des autres parents
le drame est d'autant plus cruel que cet
enfant était le seul de la famille
l'enfant unique
la règle en chine depuis 30 ans nous
avons répondu à l'appel du gouvernement
nous avons suivi les règlements déjà mes
parents n'avaient qu'un enfant et moi
c'est la même chose
toute la famille portaient ses espoirs
sur mon gars si on travaillait si on
gagnait nos premiers c'était uniquement
pour notre fille maintenant qu'elle a
disparu
je n'ai plus aucune raison de vivre à
l'extérieur du village
les slogans du planning familial sont
toujours inscrits sur les murs comme
dans tout le pays
un seul enfant c'est plus de bonheur
certes
à la campagne ou dans les minorités
notamment deux enfants sont tolérés
encore faut-il en avoir les moyens
beaucoup y ont renoncé y compris en
procédant à une stérilisation
près de 7000 classes se sont effondrés
lors du séisme
imaginez les milliers d'enfants uniques
disparu et les parents désespérés de se
retrouver seuls les psychologues venus
sur place cette semaine le savent
ce sera l'une des tâches les plus
difficiles que de consoler ses parents
espèrent que leur place et s'ils ont
perdu sept enfants c'est comme une
chaîne sanitaire se serait brisé
personne en chine nos aujourd'hui
profiter les drames survenus à ou fou
comme dans des dizaines d'autres écoles
du sichuan pour mettre en cause la
politique du planning familial
plus que jamais l'heure est à l'union
nationale pas à la polémique
on vient en france on appris aujourd'hui
que trois jeunes désespérés qu'ils
s'étaient rencontrés sur internet ont
tenté de se donner la mort dans une
forêt du nord de la france dans la nuit
de mercredi à jeudi à locquignol
précisément les trois jeunes originaires
de trois régions différentes avait via
un forum qui c'est un pacte suicidaire
mais heureusement ils n'ont pu arriver à
leurs fins julliard duperey et jean
stéphane moris la forêt de mormal dans
le nord c'est ici isolé de tout dans un
chemin boueux ou que s'est jouée la
scène seul subsiste aujourd'hui quelques
mouchoirs en papier des traces de pneus
6h30 du matin jeudi dernier deux
bûcherons aperçoivent une peugeot 405
blanche le moteur tour j'ai tout de
suite vu qu'il y avait le trio qui
sortait du pot d'échappement et qui
rentrait dans le quart arrière
donc on s'est arrêté parce que j'ai dit
ça c'est quelqu'un qui est en train de
faire une connerie et on avance et on a
vu quelqu'un qui est au volant plus au
regard d'or plus on a vu quelqu'un qui
était derrière donc on a ouvert la porte
on a coupé le moteur tu en as ouvert les
carreaux que le trouble et d'appeler des
secours les deux jeunes à l'intérieur
sont sauvés in extremis transporté à
l'hôpital de maubeuge mais l'a
rapidement les enquêteurs découvrent
qu'une troisième personne fait partie du
pacte suicidaire
une jeune fille qui elle n'est pas allée
au bout de la tentative jeune fille pour
moi elle avait quitté le véhicule vers 4
heures du matin il avait retrouvé un peu
plus loin elle se baladait sur une route
quoi et à une voiture qui passait par
l'eau qui a prévenu les gendarmes
cros et qu'il l'a emmené aux urgences à
maubeuge des trois jeunes 22 23 et 24
ans on sait qui c'est
entrée par internet sur un forum avec le
même objectif en finir avec l'âge
rendez vous est donc pris l'un des trois
quilles mercredi en voiture sa région la
bretagne
premier arrêt à tour q et à lille les
trois jeunes sont réunis
il met dans la nuit leur plan à
exécution le procureur de la république
à ordonner la fermeture du forum
internet en question
mais pour l'heure les enquêteurs se
refusent à toute déclaration pour ne pas
distille donner de mauvaises idées à
d'autres jeunes nouvelle journée de
mobilisation nationale aujourd'hui
contre les propositions du ministre de
l'éducation xavier darcos lycéens
enseignants et parents d'élèves ont
défilé côte à côte pour protester contre
les suppressions de postes ils étaient
entre 4 et 7 milles à paris l'ancien
ministre jack lang a a rejoint cortèges
en province la mobilisation était plutôt
faible la politique bertrand delanoë
réunit c'est aujourd'hui ses partisans
la mutualité à paris et il s'est dit
résolu à prendre sa part de
responsabilité dans le parti socialiste
mais à une place je cite que vous
déciderez les militants l'ont applaudi
et tout le monde a bien compris il
faudra désormais compter avec lui
reportage david humbert et alexis ports
anp
ce discours il l'avait soigneusement
préparée comme un boxeur après un combat
remporté aux points
bertrand delanoë vient de franchir une
étape importante
il n'a pas encore dit qu'il était
candidat mais il n'en est plus très loin
à partir du moment où nous lançons une
dynamique politique
tous ensemble nous lançons une dynamique
et nous cherchons à l'élargir
si en plus j'y ajoute un livre et que je
vous dis ah ben non de toute façon je ne
veux vraiment de responsabilité qu'à la
mairie de paris
je me fous de vous et bien c'est pas
dans mes habitudes
vous déciderez de ma part de
responsabilité lance le maire de paris à
ses amis comme le nouveau maire de
toulouse pierre cohen des amis qui lui
font remonter les réactions de la base
militante depuis qu'il s'est dit
socialiste et libéral
j'ai connu
là deux choses brutales mieux ce mot de
libéralisme en tout cas de liberté se
retrouvent défendue par les socialistes
que l'on croyait les plus orthodoxes
retrouvons nous les socialistes fierté
d'être musulman pour la liberté et pas
pour la liberté d'exploiter quand le
libéralisme politique n'est plus portée
à ma droite qui a les réactions
autoritaire est particulièrement
important que les socialistes revendique
sedibe et du libéralisme politique
il faut travailler sur les idées avant
de penser à 2012 ne cesse-t-il de
répéter
bertrand delanoë sabri de la pluie mais
pas d'un débat qui pourrait devenir
orageux au parti socialiste et le débat
d'idées est ouvert au ps puisque
aujourd'hui en réponse à l'idée évoquée
par bertrand delanoë que l'on pouvait
être libéral et socialiste ségolène
royal a fait savoir qu'à ses yeux ces
deux idées étaient incompatibles fin de
citation et on continue l'actualité
politique avec notre invité ancien
ministre de la ville de françois
mitterrand puis membre des radicaux de
gauche puis devenu supporters de nicolas
sarkozy il laissait entendre il ya
quelques jours qu'un retour en politique
au niveau européen n'était pas exclu
alors qu en est-il bonsoir bernard tapie
merci d'être avec nous on avait cru
comprendre que revenir en politique
c'était inenvisageable alors est ce que
on va vous voir sur une liste aux
prochaines européennes l'an prochain
j'en sais rien encore mais à l'époque où
j'étais député européen j'avais défendu
une liste qu'il a dédié un jour sans et
radicale qui s'appelait énergie
renouvelée qui comprenait des gens de
gauche et du centre droite et des gens
du centre et des socialistes parce que
le radicalisme c'est pas c'est pas
forcément la propriété dans les partis
de droite et de gauche c'est pour
salaires qui sont séparés il ya des
radicaux de gauche et des raids cobra
existe entre l'élection européenne est
un est une élection particulière mais
surtout le travail est un travail
formidable qui permet d'avoir des
activités comme vous et moi te dire dans
la société civile et de faire ce n'est
pas le cas dans les sélections
nationales j'en suis pas là du tout ah
c'est une hypothèse qui a été lancé
comme ça mais j'en suis pas du tout
encore à ce stade
pour l'instant la préoccupation c'est le
théâtre vous êtes encore proche du prg
des radicaux oui parce que lors de votre
prise de position en nombre dans la
campagne présidentielle pour nicolas
sarkozy savait créer un froid on va dire
oui mais j'ai gardé soit avec taubira
avec jean françois hory à des bleus jean
michel baylet des bonnes cité j'étais
supporters de sur les deux finalistes
problème pour moi comme pour vous c'est
un moment donné leur s ii faut choisir
et j'ai choisi sans aucun doute
nicolas sarkozy et vous avez aujourd'hui
le sentiment un an après d'avoir choisi
le bon écoutez je sais pas si tout se
passera bien et s'il pays sera dressé
mais il a deux vertus la première il
fait tout ce qu'il a dit qu'ils feraient
tout ce qu'il à vivre est alors il y en
a qui sont surpris parce que on n'était
pas habitué à ça on n'était pas habitué
à avoir un patron qui travaillent qui
fasse c'est vrai que c'est plus facile
de faire faire par les ottomans il n'y a
pas de responsabilité lui n'hésite pas à
les prendre et il sait que l'échec de sa
politique sera la sienne et vous êtes
toujours en contact avec lui vous l'avez
rencontré pas l'occasion
parce que actuellement il n'ya pas
d'élections et on n'a pas d'occasion de
se voir mais je garde pour lui
énormément d'amitié et surtout la
reconnaissance de quelqu'un qui fait ce
qu'il dit et qui tient parole dans tous
les cas de figure je crois qu en
politique ça devient une maladie de ne
pas faire ce qu'on a dit qu'on allait
faire
alors on va parler un mot du parti
saisit socialiste on vient de le voir
bertrand delanoë qui est pas encore
candidat ségolène royal il est il est il
est non c'est pas anormal que tous les
ténors du parti socialiste aujourd'hui
les gens sont effarés renoncer le
pugilat c'est pas vrai il ya leadership
du parti il faut qu'ils se réalisent les
enjeux pour l'instant c'est normal que
chacun avec sa méthode sa technique le
fasse delanoë il était il n'était pas le
candidat prévue à la mairie de paris
c'était strauss-kahn qui était prévu il
a été obligé de prendre sa place donc il
a fait un bon chemin
il avait il a parfaitement réussi son
nom son métier de maire j'ai un problème
moi vous avez lu c'est qu'on sait pas ce
qu'ils pensent sur aucun sujet il aborde
aucun des sujets ni les 35 heures n'est
la bd est en train d'arriver
il a dit quand même à ce niveau de
responsabilité on pourrait quand même un
peu savoir les ailes il a fait un livre
moi je me suis précipité dessus pour
savoir ce qu'ils pensaient et là encore
on sait pas ce qu'ils pensent on sait ce
qu'il est et c'est plutôt flatteur non
c'est pas ce qu'ils pensent les salaires
il est libéral maintenant et ségolène
royal
ah bon c'est ce qu'elle pense et c'est
en fonction de ça d'ailleurs que j'ai
pas voulu voter pour elle j'ai en moi
j'avais des éléments d analyse mais mais
mais de la nourrir on sait pas ce qu'ils
pensent et mêmes rappelez vous au moment
où il a fallu choisir un candidat n'a
même pas choisi on arrivait il est
libéral et en même temps il fait 60
pages de flatterie sur jospin alors vous
avez été proche du parti socialiste et
surtout de françois mitterrand
c'est parti françois mitterrand est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous ne faites pas le jeu
en fait de nicolas sarkozy on le sait il
a besoin de l'extrême gauche fort de la
droite du parti socialiste fort est ce
que c'est pas vous qui allez incarner on
va dire ce écouter combinant politique
réduire le parti socialiste franchement
le président a son destin entre ses
mains
il ya deux hypothèses le pays
aujourd'hui il faut savoir qu'on est 18e
par le cd aux rondes de la richesse
individuelle
c'est dire qu'on peut se raconter ce
qu'on veut on est dans un très mauvais
état
il ya deux hypothèses et d'eux seuls ou
bien ils réussi et il aura besoin ni de
moi ni de la télévision ni le personnes
et iris rannou président ou bien il
réussira pas et il a donné tellement il
a suscité tellement d'espérance aux gens
les gens tellement cru en lui qui aura
personne pour le défendre mais pour le
faire gagner sur cet espace politique on
l'a bien compris ce soir vous êtes
proche des radicaux
je suis radical et j'ai jamais été à
montjean liban l'exemple ça c'est une
idée à moi il ya trop formidable parce
que la relation de baileys bayo et
borloo est une très bonne solution
convient pas aimer de bayrou là dedans
lire j'entends des bruits selon lequel
air ou qui aimeraient se mêla et ça y
est tout sauf radical donc les
radicalismes c'est quelque chose qui se
définit facilement vous allez voir que
ça correspond pas à ce qu'il est alors
on arrête pour la politique vous restez
avec nous on passe à la page sport et ça
vous intéresse j'en suis sûr avec le
football ce soir finale de la coupe de
france lyon psg deux clubs au parcours
diamétralement opposées cette saison et
qui rêve du même trophée ce soir
atmosphère à quelques minutes du coup
d'envoi avec au stade de france
aaron en visite et matthieu nivesse le
ski
ces deux là sont fous de lyon à quelques
minutes de la finale sur le parvis du
stade de france la fièvre monte
impossible de les arrêter plus facile à
dire qu'à faire
trente cinq ans que lyon n'a pas gagné
la coupe de france alors de 7 à 77 ans
tous derrière l'ol pour l'intervenant
côté parisien maintenu tout juste en
ligue 1 c'est la calm attitude même si
les supporters rêvent secrètement d'un
exploit moi je veux tu arrivé il ya bien
marqué cap accumulant nous ce soir
d'avril une équipe de coupe et on va
gagner c'est sûr lyon est d'aimer
championnat et vont rien faire
sécurité renforcée fouille minutieuse ce
soir tout a été fait pour ne pas revivre
l'épisode de la banderole anti ch'tis
déployée lors de la finale de la coupe
de la ligue un stade plein quatre-vingt
mille supporters
que le spectacle commence alors bien
taper un mot de football un favori ce
soir
non mais c'est un formidable match je
trouve que c'est une merveilleuse
aventure pour le paris saint germain qui
après vraiment une fin de saison très
compliqué très difficile à une occasion
formidable de battre lyon qui va
évidemment essayer de faire le doublé
pour la première fois de son histoire
alors on va regarder une image il ya
quinze ans vous remportiez la coupe
d'europe champex l'om la champion's
league aujourd'hui on va dire oui ou non
il est donc aussi c'était le chant elle
déjà la champion's league face au monde
c'est avec une tête de basile boli
beaucoup d'émotion comment se fait-il
qu'aujourd'hui en france
quinze ans après un club même comme lyon
n'arrive pas à dépasser on va dire le
stade des quarts de finale et puis
effectivement que aujourd'hui on se
retrouve en finale avec quelle silver
poule
manchester united mais de le dire sur la
pelouse sur la pelouse le jour de la
finale
il y avait pratiquement chez pas lui
tout notre joueur qui était passé par
changer la france
à l'époque non seulement garder les
meilleurs français les meilleurs du
championnat de france mais on allait en
prendre en plus ceux des meilleurs des
autres championnats
on était comme les italiens comme les
espagnols maintenant on ne garde pas les
joueurs et c'est pas parce que
contrairement à ce qui se raconte ils
sont plus chers où il ya des charges
c'est pas vrai c'est que les clubs ne
veulent pas prendre au moins sur deux
saisons
imaginez lyon avec abidal avec essien
avec tous ces joueurs que c'est une
façon basse et marseille avec drogba
ribéry makelele
tous ces joueurs étaient sur la pelouse
en finale c'est alors ils ont dépensé
l'argent dans la main en disant ça sert
à rien et justement quand vous voyez le
football aujourd'hui on a parlé d'un
retour politique
un petit retour sportif il y en a qui en
rêvent en tout cas à l'olympique de
marseille
et pourquoi pas reprendre un club comme
le paris saint-germain en difficulté ces
camps en tout cas à s'accrocher
challenger j'ai pas d'argent et que dans
un club de football ça ne peut marcher
que quand celui qui commande c'est celui
qui paye pourquoi lyon ça marche c'est
son argent quand il parle un joueur il
parle de son argent un dirigeant qui est
rémunéré pour faire ce métier là il peut
par à l'autorité car un propriétaire un
mot l'équipe de france elle est en stage
atlal première chance mais aux chances à
wave vraiment on a sur le papier une des
trois meilleures équipes sinon la
meilleure donc pas bernard tapie va
gâcher pas à nos héros malheureusement
malheureusement j'ai pas les moyens
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur ce
plateau ce soir le rugby maintenant avec
la déception pour le stade toulousain
qui s'est inclinée en finale de la coupe
d'europe face aux irlandais du munster
une défaite 16 à 13 à cardiff résumé de
la rencontre avec christophe duchiron
des regrets et des remords
désigné plus noir que rouge et la
déception plein les visages n'en jetez
plus côté toulousain la coupe est pleine
au lieu de prendre la présidence de
l'europe du rugby pour un an ses joueurs
ont regardé les irlandais la province du
monster soulevé le trophée en vainqueur
avec des mines réjouies les regardant
jouer au terme d'un match parfois chris
paul
elle s'impose de la fermeture du toit du
stade toujours est il que ce rugby sous
cloche a donné en première période un
match à l'étouffée il a fallu attendre
plus d'une demi heure avant de voir un
essai que les irlandais vont marquer en
force à force d'essayer de marquer grâce
à dennis leamy alors le stade rouge de
plaisir car tous les supporters
irlandais à gicleurs chiffon rouge mais
avec un drop et une pénalité dernière
minute jean baptiste elissalde ramène et
toulouse en score 10 à 6 à la mi temps
c'est alors un grand moment
d'incertitude faites vos jeux rien ne va
plus surtout chez les toulousains la
reprise qui perdent leur capitaine
pelouse pour une expulsion temporaire de
dix minutes qui encaisse trois points de
pénalité mais qui réagissent
magnifiquement alors qu'il joue à
quatorze contre quinze
sur une relance exceptionnel de cédric
heymans dont qui récupère et aplatit
et voilà tout ce qui rend le sport 13
partout
la fâcheuse tendance au gaspillage des
toulousains va leur coûter cher
contrairement aux monsters qui joue
peut-être un rugby de petite envergure
offensive mais qui fait pas elle son
petit bonhomme de coin une pénalité pour
o'gara les irlandais passe devant 16 à
13 et jamais toulouse ne s'en remettra à
toulouse grâce à trois points toulouse
reste sur le carreau dans l'actualité
sportive également une image celle de
loïck peyron qui a remporté hier soir sa
troisième transat anglaise à boston il a
mis 12 jours 11 heures et 15 minutes et
quelques secondes pour traverser
l'atlantique
vous ne voyez pas que le skipper
français avait en plus porter secours à
vincent riou en difficulté
autres informations roland garros qui
commence demain sur nos antennes se
jouera sans jo wilfried tsonga
le français a déclaré forfait
aujourd'hui et annoncé qu'il sera opéré
mardi du genou il sera éloigné des
terrains pendant plusieurs mois
un mot de nos confrères du journal du
dimanche qui lance demain dans vos
kiosques
un nouveau supplément avec sport
dimanche ont une cette semaine yannick
noah rédacteur en chef de ce premier
numéro
bon vent à eux direction cannes
maintenant il ne reste plus qu'à
attendre demain soir pour connaître le
lauréat de la palme d'or les 22 films en
compétition tous été projetés par me
aujourd'hui entre les murs de laurent
cantet entre documentaire et fiction
aussi la vie d'une classe dans un
collège parisien marie jo juin et
mickaël cariou ont suivi les élèves
venus spécialement à cannes
il se voit déjà en star les 25 élèves
acteurs du collège parisien françoise
dolto arrive enfin après ni de cars
devant les palaces cannois pour
certaines personnes c'est le rêve de
toute une vie et nous on arrive à
l'attendre comme ça les notes premier
film à 15,14 nike quand même déjà arrêté
sur sa tombe bien je suis cité de monter
les marches
après ça me fait pas peur c'est que
démarche à lui les démarches mais celles
qui conduisent à la palme d'or le grand
jeu
la conférence de presse la séance photo
une journée magique dont ils ont
apprécié chaque instant une fille du 20e
qui vient à cannes entre les murs
pourrait être leur quotidien en collège
en 4e un documentaire mais non c'est une
fiction
ils jouent chacun un rôle et qui propose
par laurent cantet et françois bégaudeau
dans le fichier mais aussi prof dans la
ville at love qui aiment les échanges
c'était moi j'aime bien quand ça parle
j'aime bien quand c'est le bordel j'aime
bien oui j'aime bien sentir tout le
monde est là quitte à le payer du prix
de du bordel je préfère un bordel
vif que de l'attention morte a
franchement je sais pas mais s'il ya des
profs comme dit j'aimerais bien les
avoir dans quelques jours des questions
auxquelles ce sujet revient en football
on retrouve tout de suite à saint denis
denis balbir bonsoir denis avantage ce
soir à lyon mais attention à cette
équipe de coupe
qu'est le paris saint-germain oui vous
avez raison alors en cette équipe de
coupe spécialiste de coupe notamment
paul le guen vainqueur de la coupe de la
ligue et de la coupe de france en 95 et
ce serait le premier à remporter un 3e
doublé cette fois en tant qu'entraîneur
alors pourquoi pas l'équipe de paul le
guen bien sûr offensive avec miguel
pauleta métro pedro miguel pauleta qui
devrait faire ses adieux à paris et puis
de l'autre côté du côté lyonnais on
l'avait annoncé sur france télévisions
en exclusivité le 18 mars la possibilité
de quitter la france pour isoler couper
c'est chose faite maintenant pour le
gardien lyonnais qui rêve bien sûr d'un
doublé il avait six mois lorsque
l'olympique lyonnais avait remporté sa
coupe de france la dernière en 73 grâce
à bernard lacombe on verra ça affiche
très alléchante vin c'est bien sûr archi
comble et l'ambiance est belle on le
voit déjà derrière vous voilà pour
l'essentiel de l'actualité de ce samedi
merci d'être fidèle à l'information sur
france 2 la météo c'est avec isabelle
martinez 20h55 donc la finale de la
coupe de france ne manquez pas en direct
du stade de france l'olympique lyonnais
face au paris saint germain
demain dès midi france de foot avec
denis balbir on se retrouve à 13 heures
pour l'information l'invité de la page
politique sera nadine morano
très belle soirée à vous et bon foot
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr